yo tout le monde sait squeeze et je
retournais s'apprête chine mujica l'air
de force au moulin stender et que c'est
que ça un papillon aux ailes magique
péter hunter the forest tu penses que tu
meures sol mais ce n'est pas vrai
personne ne meurt seul dans ce monde
petit un trou au dessin animé chine au
mollet alors trouve la fille qui pleure
bas salaires mignon tout plein ici une
sorte de disneyland version forêt quoi
alors chez no more is suscite forest a
déjà pourquoi pouvait semer queiroz il
faut y avoir quelques soucis de forêt
soit 1.4 c'est beau c'est doux et est ce
que c'est vraiment un jeu d'horreur là
je vais pita est le pianiste s'arrête
quand en effet la fille qui pleure sans
déconner tu te calmes alors elle dans la
voiture elle se fait kidnapper pas du
tout dans le coffre belle elle sait pas
qu'il faut faire entrer en avant pour
conduire une voiture normale tout je
l'entends aller là bas là mais à un
calme toi à voile à caractère victoria
d'essonne évoqué je peux le temps dira
géniale de po la voit en train de faire
un facetime et pleurer donne presque
envie de la chine qui claque et ça c'est
moi à tanger trop le style à tout va
bien se passer
qu'est-ce qu'il faut encore là alors
qu'il fait nuit depuis quand on sait pas
barré trouvent les art fact mais c'est
quoi l'amour au taf
ok ok taipei direct dans l'ambiance mais
c'est quoi ce délire on gagne à deux
secondes sur une fille qui pleure il
faisait [ __ ] de jours il était 13
heures et là on se retrouve il est deux
heures du mat et faut trouver d art fac
on sait pas pourquoi on sait pas comment
tu attends mais qui aime je me fais
agresser d'entrée de jeu encore une
tante [ __ ] elle est la fille qui peut
en position foetale tout seul tu peux pa
menm notre approche
mais là mais what
bah oui mais bien sûr salut je suis
moche et les est bon et je suis aveugle
à je n'arrive pas à tes hanter mais je
fais quoi
mais je suis bloqué dans la tente c'est
le pire début dieu qu'on ait pu faire
sans déconner c'est kot qui prend à un
jeu d'horreur on est dans une cantine
d'un collège trouvent les couverts et
attention les brocolis en ont après toi
ce serait génial à un portail c'est
génial alors je crois que j'ai atteint
le bout de la map
une pancarte j'adore qu'on m'a dit que
mon chemin on voit rien c'est trop
éclairé mon gars shi no more et
d'afrique
l'espagnol vainqueur tranquille ou au
[ __ ] ça les connaît
pourquoi pour quelle raison je me suis
cachée voilà sinon je bouge matin tchad
mais c'est quoi ce halo de lumière quoi
cepednant tant qu'il ya cet homme c'est
un laser sont déconnectés ok le
squelette nu en mode prend position
forme dans le somnambule non mais est ce
que yann à la ja des flèches très utile
là bas des arbres là bas des arbres et
là-bas des arabes sans fin et wahaha
merci que ces leaders raté son écot
voilà moi j'ai technique qui se transmet
de père en fils selongey le portail
pourquoi perds tu es encore jeune michel
je ne comprends pas oh tu n'es pas
michel
à moins que michel est toi high five
amène à vannes en switch et la rocade
hockey ait
mais à terme et est à deux battants va
bien soit comme ça c'est par là ne
jamais changer direction ah oui un
artefact peut-être dans le coffre
ou peut-être michel michel oui bon tu as
they had ont finalement la map est aussi
grande que l'amap de gta sans les clubs
de strip-tease mon dieu
attendez on va vers le tunnel abandonné
6 à patiner à l'abandonner c'est que ces
pancartes gros et pas moyen de courir
pourquoi quand je vais clic droit il
s'arrête quoi c'est quoi utilité de
marche un jeu d'horreur sachant que
depuis le début nous suit regarde et
attend je m'attaque pas non je marche au
quai vers là il y avait deux compteurs
avec une voiture pièce un artefact comme
on ouvre comme en outre comment nous à
bec mais [ __ ] bien sûr comme par
hasard il fallait qu'il arrive à ce
moment là mais c'est ça un aspect non
c'est un pack de bière ça s'appelle
[ __ ] merde on se prenait bien aux
députés attendez je crois que j'ai
trouvé un nom en fait je peux juste ôter
ces feignasses dans un jeu d'horreur
abandonnait des tunnels tout droit là
bas je marche pendant vingt-huit années
et il n'y a pas de tunnel bordel il ya
des armes à son temps
aaaaah d'apparaître apparaître pattes
et peut-être monsieur je vous rachète
votre jeu contre ce cas caccia dans le
but de supprimer le jeu évidemment un
tunnel mais a même pas d'animation
ouagalaise c'est par là devrait avoir un
pack de bière ici pleinement mon gars ya
une main fait cette fois possible
attendez il ya des traces parterre texan
un chemin oui mon gars oh non mais je
suis revenu à la pop quart-temps face du
tunnel et qui est cet homme là on l'a
jamais vu lui avec son rouge à lèvres et
c'est son nez en forme de l'utérus j'en
peux plus les sens et connaît un peu de
soutien et à
ok maintenant si je retrouve le panneau
varinot mahmoud thiam jean mais au steak
sur foetus je m'en bats les steaks l'été
tout
du coup ok je vous la sauvez parce
qu'elle pleurait m bah tu es d'accord et
moi le premier